now it is time for tonight's hashtag war
from Donald Trump calling Jeb Bush
low-energy to Donald Trump caught on
tape bragging about sexual assault to
Donald Trump becoming the
president 2016 featured news stories as
insane and unbelievable as Donald Trump
will 2017 be anywhere nearly as eventful
only time will tell we'll have to wait
and see
or we'll wait let's all gaze into our
crystal balls with tonight's hashtag
2017 predictions mwah my first
prediction is that this guy's not
going anywhere
other examples might be
you say that here and then you'll go on
the internet and tell me how much I eat
on Twitter I have a as for you
so examples this might be Apple swings
the other way and adds to headphone
jacks or it'll finally be a wrap on
planet Earth I'm gonna put 60 seconds on
the clock and begin
Fiona black Twitter finally becomes a
separate but equal app
that bezu Trump resigns the presidency
to take over the Trump impression on SNL
all right boy Fionna
Planned Parenthood changes its name to
figure it out yourself you dumped slits
alright I'll be right there
Jimmy Fallon tarsals Putin's hair and
gets his hand dunked in acid all right
boys boy it's that better Kanye West
completes a full concert
we're never having the other jay-z
releases his follow-up to lemonade
called we were on a break alright the
first viable human clone is produced
it's a Chris Hardwick that hosts a recap
show about all the other shows that the
actual Chris Hardwick does fantastic
[Applause]